[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALEXANDRINA GARCIA-VERDIN:
I love the quote,
"Stay in a learner's mind."
Because curiosity breeds the
desire to explore and to learn.
And YouTube is a
fantastic resource
for exploring different
subjects and ramping up
on them, especially since
the tech sector is constantly
evolving.
TULSEE DOSHI: I think
one of the things that
is really unique
about tech in general
is that it's so easy
to move between roles
and between paths.
And that can be both
in terms of the role
that you do-- so whether you
are an engineer, or a product
manager, or a designer.
But it can also be a move
between verticals, right?
So whether you work on Search,
or whether you work on Video,
or whether you work on
Machine Learning Products,
or UX heavy products.
And so I would say
optimize for learning
and optimize for
what excites you.
And I think there is no such
thing as closing a door, right?
So there is always opportunities
to return to a career path
that you like.
There's always opportunities
to explore something new.
And every career path you
choose opens up a new door.
RACHEL BEEN: There is so many
careers in technology that
haven't even been created yet.
I came in to Google in
a job that didn't exist.
I was the first art
director on Android.
Some of my first jobs
were hiring illustrators
to create beautiful
artwork for Google Play.
That type of role
had never existed.
STEPHANIE WONG: Let
your curiosity lead you.
Even if your side passion might
be in the arts or humanities
space.
Allow that to infuse what you
end up doing in technology.
RACHEL INMAN: So if you're
considering different career
paths in tech, I
would definitely
recommend thinking about what
really excites you, what really
gets your energy going, and
kind of matching that up
with where your skill sets lie.
SHILPA VIR: It depends on which
stage of career you are in.
If you are a student, try
to get different internships
and try something hands-on
to see if you like it.
Talk to people in
those industries
about what their day
to day work looks like.
See if you can
shadow some of them.
See if you can do
some volunteering work
in that capacity for somebody.
And get some hands-on
experience to figure out
if this is something
that you would
enjoy doing for the long term.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Explore, explore, explore.
Do not stop exploring.
You will find that you can
match your current skills
with your passion, and really
create your own unique path
in tech that you love.
[MUSIC PLAYING]